release the Jeffree Epstein Client List
say what we know about unidentified
flying objects just give it to us
straight every
politician dances to the tomb like a
circus monkey to their biggest donor how
do you expect to unite the United States
when you struggle to do so with ryen I
think the way we're going to unite this
country is
by but before we get into it guys I've
been getting interested into politics
lately if you couldn't tell from the
guest we've had on the ice coffee hour
and I got to say I am incredibly
disappointed when I tune in to Fox or I
tune into CNN and the headlines are
completely different yet they're
reporting on the exact same thing it's
made me insanely disappointed at the
bias that exists here in the iced coffee
hour we really do our best to hear as
many different perspectives as possible
but we can't do something like this on
our own that's why we've decided to
partner with our sponsor ground news to
help bridge the gap and help get the
entire picture across ground news is an
app and website that assesses media bias
so you make sure you're not just
listening to One perspective only they
also show you the bias in specific
articles and just media in general by
indicating whether it's a left-leaning
website or a right-leaning one they also
have a blind spot feature that shows you
articles that are being under reported
by either the left or the right so that
way you could get the entire picture
understanding the bias in the media is
incredibly important if you actually
care about solving the problems and
knowing why things are happening so if
you're interested in signing up for
ground news and seeing exactly what's
going on in the media our link is down
below in the description or go to
ground. news/ IED it's only $5 a month
after getting 30% off using our link
Down Below in the description once again
guys it's ground. news/ IED for 30% off
with the link Down Below in the
description on top of it all we just
really appreciate ground news for
sponsoring this video and also just
performing the service that they do for
all of us making sure we're aware of all
of the bias that exists in media so with
that said thank you so much ground news
and on to the episode thank you so much
for uh having us on thanks for coming
over guys it's good to be here I will
say one of the biggest criticisms that
I've seen from people who watch you is
that they know your stand es they know
your policies but they feel like they
don't actually know you as a person they
kind of feel like you're this human chat
GPT yeah been but they they don't know
you so I'm curious growing up what did
you want to be you know I went through
like most young people a lot of
different phases my parents I think
acclimatized us to think of being a
doctor when we grew up my mom was a
doctor a lot of our family members
uncles and aunts were too I think that
came though from more of a place of
Financial Security my parents came to
this country with not a lot of money and
part of that immigrant mentality is just
a very defensive instinct which is how
are you going to have you know a stable
secure life so that's kind of the
defensive environment in which we were
raised I you know at points along the
way look at what other kids' parents are
doing thought maybe I would be a lawyer
at times that seemed like not a career
that called me in terms of being in a
service profession profession honestly
kept an open mind when I went into
college but there wasn't something that
I thought of that to say that this is
definitely what I want to be I had what
about as a kid you're like 5 years old
you didn't want to be an investment
banker when no I think I wanted to play
I think I want to be a basketball player
basketball yeah you're taller than I
expected you oh thank you people do say
that to me actually I don't know why
everybody tall I'm at six yeah short for
the NBA though fair not NBA standards
yeah in principle you can achieve
everything you ever want within the
limitations of what you God has given
you as your talent you realize that like
basketball's not going to be probably
around probably around fourth grade yeah
this was just realistically not going to
be I might have made the select team but
then there's the aaou league which is
yeah you guys have no reason to know
this but that's kind of where it gets
really serious and I was getting nowhere
near that and so I ended up switching
Sports to tennis where I thought I had a
better shot of actual success and ended
up you know doing well too but that
wasn't going to be in the cards to be a
professional tennis player either but a
lot of the people that I played with did
end up going to the Pro Tour and it's a
very different life how were you as a
kid growing up it's hard to know now
that I'm a parent you kind of think
about what you were like I was somebody
who probably enjoyed I was pretty social
enjoyed meeting other kids I was
probably a kid who conversed with you
know when my parents would have their
own adults or whatever over before my
younger brother was you know he's four
years younger than me but before he was
of age I was also able to probably be
comfortable talking to people older than
me or whatever that was just the
environment that my parents raised me in
I was always pretty curious I think I
like to explore new things I've always
enjoyed almost debate and arguing and
storytelling where do you think you got
that from and that inquisitive mind it's
a good question were your parents like
that some people are just born like that
I don't think I turned out the way that
my parents intended to mold me uh and
and I mean I mean that in a good way I
and I think that they wanted a guy who
put his head down followed the rules
learned how to do something useful built
a successful and stable career and a
family that had more security than they
had or felt like they had when they were
in this country that was their you know
mindset for me like the kind of thing
that you would hear in my household
growing up would not be something like
dream and be whatever you want to be
when you grow up no it wasn't that it
was you need to focus and have stability
and make sure that you have a clear path
to a stable career and that was
instilled in US starting at a very young
age and so now that I'm talking through
it with you guys when you ask me where
did that come from yeah I guess there's
something innate probably in many kids
that make them react but it over against
what their parents yeah but but there's
a reactionary Instinct and so you know I
haven't had a conversation like this in
a while but it makes me think about
maybe it was a reactionary impulse that
read led me to actually pursue a career
as an entrepreneur and live a career
life that was completely unstructured at
every step of the way it's interesting
because you kind of fit the mold of what
your parents wanted from you for a very
long time I mean especially with your
job at Goldman Sachs but then for some
reason actually what's what's really
just interesting is for me when I went
to Harvard and then had an open-ended
career plan that alone was quite a bit
of a leap and then when I decided to
potentially explore you know career
paths outside of traditional science or
medicine that itself I know I know that
the way I look at it now the way we
would look at it now is that's like a
pretty cut and dry you know assembly
line path for my family's upbringing
that was a weird thing to do that was
already off the beaten path they didn't
know anything about what that world
entailed so yes in some ways it was
itself much more conf in retrospect part
of the assembly line path to go get an
internship at Goldman Sachs but if you
asked my parents that was like a foreign
notion to them which was interesting
actually but you still tried or I guess
had that like subconscious pushing on
you that was like okay find like a
hiring job that's stable where you work
a lot which was the Goldman Sachs thing
but it seems like you still had this
like thing that you were born with that
was like okay no no no we got to do
something more creative we got to do
something higher risk it was definitely
beaten into my head so so there's you
know there's both parts of you right I
mean if we all look inside each of
ourselves and ask ourselves who are we I
mean there's the part that's beaten into
you I I guess in Freudian terms you call
that I guess the super ego or whatever
and then there's the inner self and the
combination of those two things create a
blend of who we are as people so yes
there was the part of me also that grew
up with some sense of stability and
trying the tried andrue path that's half
of me and then half of me just wants to
break that and rebel against it and or
just
explore my own creative self about where
my passions actually lead me now I would
say that in that summer internship where
where I chose probably it's probably one
of the choices if I was to go back again
I probably wouldn't have chose that
particular summer internship but I
learned a lot from it in retrospect and
yet even my senior year in college that
was part of what probably motivated me
to start my first business which I did
in my senior year after that internship
after my junior year which is my first
business that I founded but I probably
did it in some ways out of feeling
constrained by that first summer inter
so it seems like you very much want to
have free will to go with what you want
did you ever get in trouble with your
parents growing up yes I mean like but
like not nothing nothing extraordinary
fairly obedient right I mean like I
wasn't I wasn't like I wasn't the I
wasn't like a kid who I I was not the
kid who ended up in detention but you're
also highly opinionated yeah like so
back in the day when you were a kid did
your opinions ever get you into trouble
with your peers did you ever get into a
fight or did you ever like get bullied
or something so I've went to a public
school from 1st through 8th grade it
wasn't a particularly great public
school but it was a public school that
was the one we were districted in
nonetheless that was a place where
actually being the straight laced
academic you know put your head down go
to science class kind of kid wasn't
actually
particularly rewarded and so there was
probably one instance this is what
caused my parents to switch me out of
that public school to go to a Jesuit
High School there was a flight of stairs
I was carrying my science books from
class to class got pushed down that
flight of stairs resulted in me probably
I mean we think that was the cause about
few months later having to get a hip
surgery who pushed you it was a random
kid there's no way history with this kid
no it's it's actually it's actually
really interesting yeah it's really
random a lot of these kids grew up in
difficult background so this is a school
where a lot of kids in the classes they
weren't in my classrooms necessarily but
were like one or two years left behind
there was a wing of the school called
the success Wing which is the wing that
they would tell kids like me to stay
away from CU these are kids who maybe 14
15 years old but are still in you know
seventh grade but they called it the
success that's that's the wing that they
called sounds C it is the success Wing
was I probably I went there for one
class ever but the success Wing was the
wing that you stayed out of but yeah
it's a place where you know you got a
nerdy kid with you know glasses and
carrying a science textbooks from class
to class who's an academic guy that's a
Target but that was also a good
experience for me
because you know you're an outsider in
that setting that's fine but I went to a
different School setting Where I Was an
outsider which was STX High School in
Cincinnati so that was a Catholic High
School I was a lone Hindu kid and that
was also an interesting learning
experience too and so I've probably
always been in settings where I have
been comfortable grew to be comfortable
I would say in being in settings where I
was you know often the odd man out so
and that's kind of was was my big part
of my what happened to the bully
afterwards guy pushed you yeah I mean I
don't think it was like I didn't go
running to a teacher we didn't like I
don't I mean it was I think probably
nothing I can't I couldn't even remember
who the kid was wasn't a kid who's in my
classes or in you know cuz we were you
know they had slightly advanced classes
or slightly remedial classes there were
different classrooms but in between
classes it's the same group of kids
going together in one school and yeah
probably nothing happened you actually
like tumbled down a flight of St yeah
would push down a flight of stairs wow
okay it happens it's the kind of stuff
that goes you know grown up it's
probably the biggest instance of what I
would call the closest thing to bullying
that I experienced but it was definitely
something that you know a teacher of
mine then pulled my parents aside when
they picked me up from school like you
need to get this kid the heck out of
here and he was a teacher in that school
so when I was in high school I observed
two different predominant archetypes of
of the student which is like those who
work extremely hard and have to study
consistently to get good grades and they
feel pressured usually by their parent
parents or by some other factor to like
put their noes to the book and like
grind versus those where School kind of
just came easy they would get good
grades but they wouldn't have to study
as much as the other person I'm
wondering which one of those two would
you say you were because I see you
you're like Ultra successful right
hundreds of millions of dollars you're
running for for president which is just
insane like which one which archetype
would lead to this future I don't think
that you could necessarily predict one
as a path I I think one of the things
I've I mean that's just my honest answer
if if I was to think back which one I
fit there's probably elements of both I
mean we did have parents who were very
focused on the traditional path
educational achievement come home do
your homework Etc but did it come easy
to you but but yeah I mean I think that
everybody has their native talents and I
think you know doing well in school was
something that I was naturally prone to
do and and you know write or read or
learn or do math well yes I mean joining
the NBA wasn't in the cards for me but
the equivalent of that for academic
achievement was just to be blunt about
it and so I'm not sure that it's the
compliant shut up sit down do your
homework mentality that automatically
yields a particular result I think it's
different for different people I mean my
wife was maybe on the other side of that
she's also incredibly academically
successful you know one of the smartest
people I've met but you know I think
that for her it was much more
libertarian in her in her upbringing
compared to my parents Focus just cuz
they moved around to different places
and so it was her love of learning that
guided her I also had a natural love of
learning but it was in a environment
that was much more structed but I think
it would be probably um reductionist and
you know overly trying to fit a square
peg into round hole kind of thing to
sort of think that there's one
trajectory of Parental upbringing that
leads to one thing and another draw
patterns like if you have disciplinarian
parents that tell you this is the
structure that you should be and then
you have to learn and teach yourself to
like to be disciplined to do all of your
work work and to you know read the cross
your te's and Dot your eyes and stuff
like that I do think that that does have
some long-term effect contrary to the
person that has like the natural innate
inherited intelligence that learns to be
lazy they learn they can cut corners and
stuff like that and it comes from a more
like creative problem solving type brain
I think so I think that if we're going
to draw that out though I think that
there's definitely more than two tracks
those are the I would say like those are
the two predominant archetypes that I
observed in high school how old are you
if you don't mind me 24 you're 24
actually oh yeah 2 what's that 33 you're
33 yeah oh look you look younger thank
you um you're not at an age where that's
a compliment yet it's just a it's just a
fact uh now that I've become a parent
myself and also just reflecting on
seeing a lot of people who have pursued
a lot of different
Journeys I think that when kids show up
like even at like a very like a very
young age in many ways they're wired
they are who they are they're just like
I've got two young Sons they're both one
of them's three and a half one of them
is a year old they're very different
people and we're raising them in the
same
circumstances like we're not doing
anything that's that different for one
than the other but they're just they're
different pred elections one of them
talked earlier than the other one the
other one got up on his feet and is like
far more physically dextrous and and
physically exploring versus the other
guys more verbal and emotionally
exploring and I think that in some ways
we're each
the cake isn't fully baked but like it's
like a half baked cake when it shows up
and so how much ever you will to tame
that or mold
that I think is a failed Pursuit
versus then there's the separate
question of are you in an environment
where that inner self is able to become
the maximal version of whatever it's
going to be versus an environment that
sometimes can choke that out of
existence for a long time or an
environment that you know and this might
have been my experience of this that
wasn't really like fitted to what my new
true inner nature was but that actually
helped me hone it and Discover it even
more I think that was my experience of
it it depends on what kind of underlying
person almost was born into their bodies
that found themselves in that
circumstance so I'm curious if you could
change anything with the way your
parents raised you what do you think
that would be I'm not sure I would I
wouldn't be who I am you know you're
we're all we're each the product of our
own experiences so I'm not there there's
a few cases where I might look back in
life and say there's a few things that I
would have done differently and even
still there's not that many of those
because like I'm not even a person to
dwell on that maybe I should have taken
Spanish instead of French in high school
like that'd be that'd be on the list for
me I would have been better at speaking
the relevant language cuz I would have
used it more
but I don't I'm not wired to think about
that because the truth is who I am today
is absolutely a product of the
experiences that led me here and so to
say that I would have wished for one of
those experiences that was different
either in a decision that I made or that
my parents made is almost like rejecting
some aspect of myself today but I guess
how are you parenting your children
differently than how your parents raised
you well I think there's a couple
realities um one is our children grow up
in far more comfortable circumstances
than I did I think that that raises both
opportunities and concerns I worry a
little bit about I think part of who I
am the scrappy nature of who I am comes
from a kind of insecurity that you pick
up from your parents it's hard to
recreate something that isn't you know
NE manufactured a little bit yeah
exactly and on the flip side I think
that we
are wide open to our kids deciding for
themselves what it is discovering for
themselves what it is they want to do my
my older son right now wants to be a
fighter jet pilot that was not within
the Overton window of acceptable career
options that sounds fun though yeah it
does sound fun actually but as a father
I bet you that's a little cons like oh I
think I think actually not at all you
don't think so I think
and that's that's totally so nervous for
the safety of my kids oh
they even if he goes up and become a
fighter jet pilot that's that's
something he's passionate about doing
that's pretty awesome cool and and I
think that that's just a different
Outlook now it's interesting to think
about
this I can't say that one of those
approaches is better or worse than the
other it's just the nature of where we
are in our lives versus where our
parents were in their lives and I'm a
product of that upbringing that would
bring up my kids in a different way than
my parents did but that doesn't mean
that I wish that my parents did it any
differently that makes for your kids
would it bother you if they wanted to
pursue a career that made no money
whatsoever like let's just say I want to
totally fine with that okay absolutely
so it seems like your parenting style is
like worlds different than the parenting
style you were subjected to when you
were a kid cuz you're like do whatever
you want kids yeah so it did we want we
try to teach them we we we do our best
them yeah and also understanding the
consequences of their actions but to
empower them to be able to make those
decisions for themselves interesting
absolutely but would you want them if
their future career made no money would
you feel good supporting them
financially through that like let's just
say they wanted to be an artist let's
just say they made no money whatsoever
but they're like I love art I'm
passionate about this then the money
would have to come from somewhere well
uh if you're a good artist maybe the
money comes from making so there's that
so I think that there's a sweet spot
zone for the optimal upbringing that you
maybe be able to give your kids from a
material perspective I think that if you
don't have enough money to send your
kids to a good school and you're in a
bad school district or whatever and this
is relates to my policy issues which we
can talk about another day then I think
that you're at a disadvantage I mean if
you're not able to get the same kind or
quality of Education as peers your age
you're at a disadvantage on the other
hand if you're raised in circumstances
where you have nothing to actually
aspire to because you're just showered
and swimming in wealth that it crowds
out your own ability to have hunger and
scrappiness and I've gone to college and
La school and otherwise with people who
fit that description I think that's a
kind of disservice that you can do for
your kid as a parent too and so our goal
for our kids will
be allow them to have the true
luxury this is a real luxury to be able
to pick the career that allows you to
follow your passions without fear of
putting food on the dinner table but
that doesn't mean that you have a right
to fly around in a private jet right
because of the career that you chose do
you think that might stifle motivation
knowing that there's always a fall back
yeah I wonder about it um am I I mean I
think that I think that that's a risk
you know a lot of kids might end up I I
know a lot of people who have ended up I
think some of them are and my own
extended family who ended up in careers
that're they're like fine or
perfectly complacent with but isn't
exactly what they would have chosen if
they were following their true passion
they did it out of the need for
achieving a level of Financial Security
and then they pursue hobbies that may
more align with their passions and and
nothing to say with the anything wrong
with that model I I suppose most people
work for the sake of putting food on the
dinner table but make sure that work
isn't the entirety of their life so that
they're able to pursue their passions
outside of work I'm a little bit
different the path I've pursued is one
where I don't really draw a distinction
between work and hobby and passion and
pleasure the way I'm spending my time
all the time as best I can is directed
towards something that I'm incredibly
passionate about and that's the
ultimate win I think is to be able to
live a life where you're able to do that
you can't do that if you
literally I mean we're human beings we
like have certain basic needs you need a
shelter over your head or food or drink
for sustenance right so if you literally
can't do those things then yes you're
not able to achieve self-actualization
by following your passions through your
work I think that what the the boundary
we'd like to draw for our kids is to
give them the opportunity to pursue
their passion without fear of putting
food on the dinner table fine but that
doesn't mean that you're going to live a
life of opulence and luxury
automatically because of that either no
that could come through being an
exceptional artist or musician or
creator of whatever kind you want to be
but part of the trade-off of making
whatever Choice it is is you're
passionate enough to do that regardless
of whether that's the actual reason
you're doing it to accumulate green
pieces of paper that's not a reason to
pursue a track as uh singer or a artist
or whatever you should do it because of
your passion and if you were doing it
because it was going to accumulate you
green pieces of paper that's not
following your passion that's just the
equivalent of going to work as a you
know a a janitor or a cab driver or
anything else that's doing it for the
money do that make sense what are your
hobbies outside of work what do you
enjoy to tell you the truth I do I know
you like I know you love work I'm the
same way but like if if you take that
aside I play tennis beses okay yeah I'm
a tennis fanatic okay uh the the
presidential campaign has not been great
for my tennis game but until this kicked
off probably uh probably since I was
like since I turned turn maybe 29 or 30
for the last seven eight years yes
tennis has been a big passion both
watching okay and playing I I used to
play growing up and so that's something
that I try to keep up as much as I can
is there anything besides that in terms
of like fun hobbies so when kids came
into the picture that one of the things
is that does eat into your H you got to
pick you got to pick one or two I did
enjoy for a while um good film and good
theater like good movies and Andor good
live production
yeah so that would be something and then
writing is a hobby of mine too actually
just free form carry around notebook
long form writing and some of the
argumentative stuff sure I'll publish
and you can see it and you know where
wherever I've published this stuff it's
probably what resulted in me writing
three books over the last couple of
years I I was probably a suppressed
author without knowing and so writing is
is a hobby of mine as well you've also
mentioned before that you are vegetarian
for religious and moral reasons
and that you also don't in any s of
drinking or like smoking as I'm just
curious like why do you decide to like
how is it a moral reason to be
vegetarian from your perspective because
for me I like eating me I think it
tastes great and all but morally I'm
conflicted on it how do you draw that
distinction between like okay for your
own personal sake you deem it as immoral
yeah and also for the other vices well I
think that I think those the choices
that we make in our own lives that are
totally different from the policy
perspectives of course that we offer on
others right so I've been a CEO of a
company well do we serve meat at company
events yes we do because I believe that
each person is able to make the choices
that they deserve to make that's best
for them and certainly from a
policymaking perspective I'm a hard
libertarian when it comes to people
being able to make whatever decisions
suit them and not legislating one form
of morality so put that to one side I
was raised in a vegetarian household but
the reason I remained vegetarian is that
all else equal I would rather not kill
an animal for my culinary pleasure if my
life depends on it absolutely not going
to think twice if my nutrition actually
depends on it like if if I'm going to be
less healthy in some way absolutely I
would I would do it in a heartbeat no
problem because I do think that that's a
trade-off that's Justified if it's going
to allow us to live a more effective
life than absolutely so are there
circumstances in which I would do it
absolutely but I'm able to get that in
ways that don't
require killing a sentient being if I
can do it that way I'll do it that way
that's the way I look at it and then
what about the no drinking stance I'm
not I'm not a hardliner I just prefer
not to be intoxicated I prefer to be in
control like that's just part of the
freakish nature of my control freak
nature of myself is I don't want to do
things that like everything I want to do
I want it to be a conscious decision
when did you make that decision when did
you realize that probably like pretty a
pretty young age I mean I like to be in
control of the situations that I'm in
and I think that I've seen what it's
done to friends and I don't care to
subject myself to addictions that allow
me to lose control over myself or who I
am was there a specific moment that's
not a moral decision right I think
there's nothing there's nothing immoral
about about having alcohol or nothing
immoral about smoking a cigarette those
are Health decisions that you want to
make for yourself was there a specific
moment though that changed your opinion
on drinking or smoking no I don't think
so I think
that I'm openminded I mean it's not like
it's not like I won't have a sip of
alcohol but it's like it's not like it's
like poison have to like spit it out
right but I just don't like being
intoxicated and I think that I did grow
up in a household or neither of my
parents drank so maybe that was sort of
an A in natural conclusion for me to
come to
I also have friends who have become
alcoholics and have suffered through
that that reinforced my belief set as I
grew up it's the same part of me that
likes to get a good night of sleep I
feel good and at my best the next day
that I don't want to feel hung over the
next day and I don't want to feel
inebriated when I'm enjoying life plenty
as it is I don't even drink c i I rarely
drink caffeine actually I don't have
coffee I have enough energy as it is
where does the energy come from we
recently had a guest on our podcast that
said what was it like of the Uber
successful there is a hypomania it's a
very very rare trait or Gene that some
people have it's like a super Gene where
it means that you can get crazy energy
off of very little sleep I get I I for
better or worse I have a lot of energy
so you probably have dist yeah I don't
know I don't know about the term but I
uh definitely am somebody who has a lot
of energy as long as I'm doing something
that that I think is worthy and
interesting MH yeah I can run on very
low fumes and be pretty high functioning
so I'm curious who else in your family
has that trait my mom has that trait for
sure there we go she is uh also not a
coffee drinker okay and and like to tell
you the truth I don't know what would
happen if I drank coffee like I think I
might explode it might it's like I would
love to see this yeah it's it's probably
not great even if I have like a tea and
I get you going gets it gets it's it's a
little bit like I'm not even thinking
clearly especially if I'm like tired
like after not like a great night of
sleep but then have a tea it's like oh
no I can't deal with that I'd rather not
have the caffeine and I'm I'm good at
finding the our prior guest said that a
lot of that is genetic that you would
inherit that trait from a parent or
close relative yeah I bet that's genetic
interesting yeah huh I want to talk a
little bit about there's far more that's
genetic than we understand for sure
that's we're wired the way we are and
that that goes to my whole point about
the upbringing piece of this is I just
think it is overly false Precision
to think that there's some kind of
formula to all of this we're complicated
beings each of us is unique in our own
ways and to think that some model of
molding you is going to result in some
very precise outcome I just don't think
it works that way how much would you say
is genetic versus
upbringing in terms of maybe someone's
success life motivation future I mean
both are important but I think that we
would like
to the the fairy tale side of us wants
to say that you can achieve anything you
want with your own hard work and
commitment and dedication the fact of
the matter that's not true there's no
chance I was ever going to make it to
the NBA despite the fact that I would
have wanted to when I was in second or
third grade and so I think what I think
of as this isn't exactly your question
but just to get my own thoughts on the
table is what do I think of as the
spirit of what we mean when we say that
in America meritocracy or Merit or
unbridled Excellence what do we mean is
whatever your god-given talents are and
each of us the three of us I'm sure have
three different ones whatever they are
any two different people have different
god-given talents whatever your
god-given talents are that you live in a
society that allows you to achieve the
maximum of your god-given potential
without anybody standing in your way
right so that's what I think about
that's what I think is beautiful about
this country that was the opportunity
that I was given in this country I think
that's the opportunity this country
gives everybody that's what's special
about the United States of America how
much of that is god-given Talent versus
god-given Gifts of other kinds like
parenting or circumstance or otherwise
depends on the attribute you're talking
about I mean if you're talking about
athletic Talent well let's talk about
Athletics I think that if you want to be
anywhere from the zeroth to the 70th
percentile most of it is probably just
effort and commitment and passion and
dedication if you want to go
the difference between like the 998th
percentile and the 99.9th percentile
it's absolutely genetics that make that
difference of the increment of whether
or not you're able to go that final
distance controlling for somebody who
has been passionate in that in that
respect and so so we could say that for
athletics but I think there's probably
other domains of life for which that's
generally true too and so I hate to draw
an overall rule of thumb but we use the
Athletics as a model it's probably not
too far off the mark for other domains
that we could think of too to say
if you want to be in the 0 to 70th or
even the 0 to 90th percentile of a given
domain which is to say pretty darn good
better than N9 out of 10 people who do
it your effort and your dedication and
your hard work and your passion and your
upbringing and your
commitment will get you pretty much as
far as you want to go but if you want to
go to that final increment of being that
what we call we call it that for a
reason freak of nature right and the
people who are winning championships in
athletics or comparable non-athletic MH
domain s the true freaks of nature we
call them that for reason is that it was
a product of you know nature actually
it's both I feel Bryant you know yeah I
mean no mean yeah Kobe Bryant no matter
you could have somebody else I would
venture to say you any of the three of
us that worked as hard on the basketball
court as Co BR we're still not going to
be we're still not going to be doing
what he was doing at at the peak of his
game and that's okay it's a beautiful
thing we should celebrate that you think
about it why are we opposed to athletes
using
performance-enhancing drugs or anabolic
steroids or whatever is that it ruins
our ability to celebrate that
native Talent right I mean like let's
say we talk about Kobe Bryant maybe 30
years from now we can have ai programmed
humanoid robots that will do on a
basketball court what like the
combination of Kobe Bryant LeBron James
could never do or on a tennis court
Novak jokovic could never dream of doing
I wouldn't want to watch that now some
people might say I'm wrong about that
maybe we will and I would draw a
distinction the thing you'd be admiring
there would be like computer programming
coding right so there may be room for
like we talking about tennis and pickle
ball there may be AI ball later which is
like the equivalent of like the AI
version of humanoid you know AI program
robots playing tennis and they're like
hitting the ball like way harder than
like a normal human tennis player is but
you're admiring a different thing right
there and in some ways that's even part
of what's baked
into why we separately enjoy men's and
women's sports differently I'm just
thinking out loud it kind of reminds me
of that's probably why both are you if
you want just the people going to hit
the hardest or Pat or or just like see
the ball fly the fastest that's not what
you're really admiring you're admiring
people competing to the outer edge of
what natural capability endows combined
with effort and I think there's
something about us that admires that so
like you know me men's women's sports we
can celebrate each one differently
partly because that's what's baked in
what were you saying about F1 F1 a lot
of people that celebrate F1 surprisingly
are Engineers like mechanical engineers
because they love to all of the stuff
that goes into creating the vehicles
it's not necessarily like watching a
bunch of people go super fast around a
track my friend mechanical engineer is
like super into all of that stuff not
for like watching the races but like the
mechanics behind building such a machine
yeah it's a great point and so I think
we can admire different things in
different experiences
but it's okay to acknowledge that some
of that
is nature that we're celebrating
expressed through us as human beings and
that's that's a beautiful thing too I do
want to bring up relationship advice cuz
you said in your book woke Inc that your
parents got an arranged marriage yeah
which is I mean like growing up in the
United States Growing Up in Southern
California is nuts to like like we think
that that stopped existing 100 years ago
it's nuts but it's not as nuts as you
think actually cuz it's kind of come
full circle well they've been married 40
years sucess you also said wasn't the
marriage like 12 days after their first
real date it was like less than less
than two weeks can you walk us through
how does that happen so two families get
together they each Pi they knew each
other before right thees didn't know
each other before but they knew of each
other like via VIA Network so so my mom
was living up and grow up in my store
which is one part of India my dad was in
Cara and Via family networks and there's
a lot of prev vetting that went into it
we're like all right they're both
educated they're both like even like
there's not some major mismatch in
height right like like there's a lot of
factors that go into this right where
they you know academically inclin they
know what each other's interests are but
what did they think about it like your
dad and your mom weren't they like I
want
toing nobody's forcing it on they're
down they're cool the final consent for
the decision but to put them together
and then say hey if you guys want to go
with it go with it that sounds nuts
compared to the environment we grow up
which is like which is different than
I'm we're about to get to where we are
now but the environment that I grew up
in was one where you would date people
that you might meet at school or at a
bar or in a neighborhood or whatever and
have an organic interaction that guides
you all the way now to gen 3 where you
have an algorithm that asks you for your
preferences and asks you about your
height right or left
that exactly so that seems a lot more
similar to
me than like to to what my parents
arranged marriage was you're arranged by
AI today instead of arranged by human
beings who love you so I like the way it
went for me which was my wife and I met
at a party and it and we were naturally
drawn to each other and we had an
immediate human chemistry that we Then
followed and led us to the life that
we've pursued and that's cool but but
that's but what what the irony now yes
we can look back and say like arranged
marriages are weird but it's equally
weird from my frame of mine to look at
like algorithmically set up anonymity
for swiping left and right there's
senses in which I mean I just went to
wedding with one one of my best friends
who met exactly in that same setting but
it felt like it wasn't so different than
the setting in which my parents met
which is kind of funny and interesting
how did they get married after 12 days
why 12 days is it like after that after
a week if you ask me so I'm not
endorsing was that their parents saying
get married after 12 days or were they
just like I think it's like I think it's
sort of somewhere in between where now
you can also look at like people who I
know maybe you guys know as well who've
like yeah we've been together for six
years and we're we're deciding whether
we want to get engaged at a certain
point it's like dude have some
conviction in your relation what do you
feel like is too long what do you feel
like it's true right like it's a fair
what's too long to get engaged what
would you say as a point where as a guy
it's like by this time what's Too Short
what's too long from your perspec broad
Strokes we understand this is not uh
we're not making policy right we're uh
maybe we should I just think like if I
was talking to a friend yeah right and
my friend has been like if he's been
engaged for three years but they're
postponing the wedding I was like
something's off interesting something's
off right why get engaged then right or
or why why have the level of partial
commitment without just going all in so
that's that's that's an instinct that's
baked in there does that mean 12 days of
the Right End are probably not in the
modern society but part of these are
societal Norms that are baked into the
society you grow up in and so I think if
your engagement is measured in years
well I'm saying at least my friend think
about it from the time of meeting
somebody to the time where you get
engaged like how long does it take to
get to know some person I I think that a
lot of people though would tell you who
are in happily married relationships
that are built to last and I'm grateful
and feel
fortunate to the world to God that I'm
in one of those relationships now but I
think I'm one of these people but many
people I know who tell you the same
thing within a matter
of weeks and at times within days you'll
know you know wow yeah that's crazy so
against that backdrop like 12 days isn't
nuts but if like I think if you're
talking about within a period of months
if you're serious right like it's one
thing to just be like I'm hanging out
with this person and I'm dating like
five you know whatever I don't you know
what the culture is right now but dating
five people at the same time and you
know I'm not going to it's not it's not
like a particularly
serious you know relationship put that
to one side but if you're actually in a
monogamous single person to single
person committed relationship where
you're invested in getting to know the
other person and vice versa chances are
that if you are going to fast forward
that 40 or 50 years and say that that
worked more often than not you knew that
within the first several months of first
probably three months of being in that
relationship okay a couple of points on
this because we just had Ben airo on
recently and he said the exact same
thing he was yeah because because he
married or he proposed to his wife like
two months right it early after they
first met it was very quickly after they
first met but like that doesn't strike
me as crazy right like you know they
great relationship playing with kids
together so as someone in the dating
pool currently what I'm so scared about
is getting into a relationship and not
feeling that immediate connection you
don't be scared of it but here's the
thing it's like I view relationships as
a certain threshold that you have to
exceed and you're like okay a threshold
of compatibility now I know I can be
with this person for the rest of my life
but I do think that there is that like
pinnical relationship where you do meet
someone and like right off the rip
you're like okay this is my person it's
like am I going to subvert my
expectations to to being you know
exceeding that threshold of
compatibility or for normaly but there
there there comes a time where you can't
continue to date for 20 years and hold
out for that Pinnacle relationship
because then you'll be too old no I know
I think that some of this is just you
there's there's certain things
that are in the cards for you in life
and certain things that aren't and I
think there are many people who could be
happy mhm in a long run lasting
relationship with the person who
probably still isn't their
soulmate and that's a tough position to
be in but you know what there's worse
things that happen in life too to a lot
of other people that may never find that
or may never find internal satisfaction
either so I can't speak for that one of
the things I am most grateful for in my
life is that I was in a position to say
that very quickly here's a person I met
and this was made to be and it's obvious
with within a matter of months and so
we're just mhm you know fate is sealed I
wish that for every
person you're asking for the scenario of
what happens if I'm not that I'm just a
personal concern of mine because I've
always held out for like I'm going to
meet that person where it's going to be
like 12 days boom right yeah I'm
tomorrow I'm 25 25 happy birthday thank
you thank you so give yourself a few
years and I would say that probably
there's a life staging thing I guess I
haven't been asked for this advice
before so you know
take it with a grain of salt but I think
it's probably a life staging thing where
you give yourself the next 10 years to
open yourself up to that possibility and
my advice during those 10 years would be
don't waste time in a like a multi-month
relationship where you know that that's
not going to be that's not going to be
fitting like if three months in you're
not sure move on that'd be my advice for
the at least the next 10 years of your
life now you might get into your like
mid or late 30s later on and you feel
like you want to live a life that brings
children into this world that find
somebody you're compatible with that
maybe doesn't meet this idic standard
you can turn to that later but give
yourself the next 10 years to give
yourself the maximal chance as opposed
to I think what I've seen many of my
friends go through as well is you know
I'll be in a relationship where it's
compatibility for like 3 four years but
then you get to late 20s and you're like
29 and you're like what do I do with
that and that was something that
probably many of them regret right you
could have that what was four years
could have been four months and give
yourself I think the opportunity so that
that be my like for you specifically in
the Life Stage you're in thank you for
the relationship be the advice you asked
to tie off to tie the not on this to tie
the that's on this whole relationship
thing the one thing that you said that
was super fascinating was comparing
modern like on algorithm based apps to
arranged marriage but the difference is
in arranged marriage the people that
probably know you most intimately know
your character know your values your
personality belief systems versus you
selecting for yourself what you're
interested in which is the the modern
dating way and I find that a lot less
effective and if I'm referencing if I'm
correct it's Carl Young Who said when it
comes to judging one's own character
everyone is horrible something like that
like judging others than your own let me
let me say something about that I think
the people who are making the modern
dating apps would say something
different is it's not even you choosing
it oh the AI will know better than you
what you're being
served just because you put in your
preferences of what you want to see
right the feed you it's actually going
to feed you want they give you the
people that like you continue to date
and stay on the app rather than the
they're not about matching people the
app so there's some that some I mean I'm
not seems like most want to keep you on
as long
tind is something heard they show you
the most attractive people first you
swipe on them and then it shows you an
attractive it's like a a slot machine
they show you an attractive person I
think it was like every like 12 to 15
times they to keep you on there yeah
exactly so so I mean different I'm not
up on the latest of what the competitive
landscape of these dating apps look like
from but but I would imagine there's a
market Niche for at least back in the
day there used to be the ones that would
you know was it e-harmony or which one
that would sort of promise you more that
what you're in this for is not something
in short run but something that's long
run and Lasting but my only point is the
real question and the real debate is do
you trust an algorithm to do that well
or do you trust the people who know you
best know you best to do that well and a
network and a tradition that makes that
happen so I'm certainly not planning to
and we have no vision that that's how
things are going to play out for our
kids it's not how play out for me but
all I'm saying is what seems even to me
growing up super weird as a model
now that we've entered the postmodern
world it actually makes that previous
super weird model of my parents seem a
little less weird than it once did
because the postmodern world isn't all
that different it does seem though that
there would be more pressure on your
parents to get married because of all
the family pressure that they put on the
two versus them coming to their own
decision they could say well if our
parents you know say it's good wouldn't
that have such a big influence on them
to believe it's probably did that
marriage is inherently good
the stigma of divorce as well like for
the cohesiveness of arranged marriages
there is a huge stigma in those
communities they got divorced and their
family made that decision divorce rates
are great amongst arranged marriages
from what I've heard the divorce rates
are like but part of it might account
for what you just said which is that if
it's tradition that brought you together
via an arranged marriage it might be
tradition that keeps people together in
unhappy marriages too I don't think
that's most of what's going on but to be
fair that's that's you know a
possibility in certain cases I am
somebody who in believes that all else
equal I mean each person's different
this doesn't mean for every individual
but all else equal marriage is
inherently good MH bringing children
into the world in the context of a
married household with two parents in
the house is inherently good I don't
know that it's such a bad thing for us
to adopt that cultural norm I don't
think the government should be enforcing
it but I far from it but I think it's
okay for us
to embrace a culture that is that all
else equal we're rooting for you MH to
get married ideally finding I would age
that that soulmate and that becomes part
of a general cultural norm versus the
postmodern slide of well maybe I will
maybe I won't well maybe I'm a man and
maybe I'm a woman right I mean it it
just it just goes to it can it can go to
a level of once you sort of feel like
you're removing a lot of
constraints what it turns out you're
doing is you're actually just creating
new ones that often can leave you far
worse off as a result and so I think
it's this tricky thing where it's like
the Paradox of choice yeah yeah I think
I think yes I think it's well said I
think that you can become a prisoner of
what you feel like the op is the optical
illusion of choice when in fact it's
just a new kind of
prison and so I think we need some level
I think I think we probably benefit with
some level of default structural Norms
in a culture in a society that we still
have the freedom to opt out of for sure
and I think that's probably the optimum
that I would want to create for my kids
and not just using governmental power
but as a cultural norm I think that's a
good thing in our country to create a
certain default ordering but there's
always going to be people for whom the
right answer still isn't fitting in that
order there's still a path to opt out
and you know I guess I guess that's
probably what my parents had right I
mean if my my mom or my dad either of
them said after those 12 days they don't
want to do it nobody was going to force
them to do it but there was a heavily
you know heavily culturally informed
expectation that there's a good chance
this is going to work and as long as you
have that opt
out now this not we're just talking
about marriage we're talking about
really anything MH right that if you're
a man
you dress a certain way there are
certain you compete in certain Sports in
certain ways but
if you're a fully grown adult and you
want to do it
differently we're not going to stop you
no one's going to come to your house
with the handcuffs and say you can't do
it but that if you bastardize and
pervert that fetishization of choice to
say that there's no default Norm at all
and there shouldn't be those defaults I
think you're just creating a new form of
Oppression and depression as a
consequence and I think that's I think
we're we're veering too far in that
direction age with that but I also think
that we do need to appreciate those that
do go away from the norm whether or not
we like embellish it and like you know
what I mean like recommend it is a
different thing but we do need to
appreciate and respect the uh you know
the abstraction from the norm yeah of
course yeah for those for those for whom
that's the right choice okay so now
we're going to go into more of like a
policy thing by the way I read woking I
loved it I loved it and I want to say
I've always intuitively thought that
there is so much co-mingling between
Corporate America and like bureaucrats
like intuitively it made so much sense
to me but I never really felt like I had
like that confirmation but this book
just like I feel like I you know what I
mean like the Matrix got opened which is
insane and I'm not just like a fullon
just like believer of everything it was
a it was a very honest book I mean I
I was not really filtering very much in
that book it was what I felt at the time
I put it on a page and that was that
book yeah but no one's open about this
cuz especially the people that they
control the dissemination of information
right you know what I mean so obviously
why would they out themselves as the
people that muddy the waters right so it
doesn't really make any sense but I I
really liked that book and I'm going
recommend it to a lot of people yeah I
hope a lot of young people read it I
mean it's it seems a little less bold
today than it was oh come on a minute
some people than it was at the timean at
the time when I wrote that book the
stuff in there you were not allowed to
say it right but it's so abstract still
and I do think that you go a little too
nuanced and like deep about it where I
think if you made it more of like a the
problem with nuanced opinions which is
exactly what that whole book is yeah
we're rolling the problem with nuanced
opinions is the fact that you need to
justify it with so much data so much
like supporting information that nobody
is willing to pay attention to and I
found that to be one of the biggest
issues today is that a lot of the times
the correct opinions are the nuanced
ones but it's not exciting and it does
require a lot more information too much
thinking exactly and your book was
exactly that it's like in order to
understand that framework you do need
all that supporting information but
nobody's going to go out of their way to
figure it out well I hope that we change
that because I think the truth is
sometimes nuanced for sure and sometimes
requires getting Beyond just what is
built to trend on algorithmically
powered social media and I do worry
about the discursive impact of an
Internet that was built to mimic real
life and then we now have real life
mimicking the internet and I think that
that's something I worry about I don't
have an obvious answer of how to change
it make it more exciting somehow yeah I
I don't know how but like like the truth
isn't exciting enough you know what I
mean at times I I I think there's a
difference between exciting and
beautiful sure but I mean enticing like
people want to try to reach the truth
how do we make that more I would say you
know enticing mhm appetizing why is that
desirable to reach the truth no to make
it more appetizing because then I think
people digest it I think it's people are
more receptive to surface level basic
ideas they don't need to think too much
about uh but that interests them and so
how could you get people interested
something if it takes too much work if I
mean it's it's it's a kind of an age-old
question of
like what if you have a good
product but you don't Market it well
yeah what's the point of having a good
product but you got you have to operate
within the constraint of making sure the
marketing of the product doesn't change
what the product actually is and so you
know the truth in this particular case
of deep debate about cultural and
political you know circumstance s in the
United States in the year 2020 when I
wrote that book is there a more
effective way to Market that to reach a
larger number of
people without changing the
underlying truth of what you're
communicating I'm sure there is and I'm
sure that I probably have been less
effective than I than I can be but for
me my goal in writing that book was not
to reach the maximal number of people it
really wasn't it was to it many was
practicing out a hobby mhm
pretty long form writing exactly and and
if I write down there what I actually
mean and you know nobody reads it but 10
people yeah that'd be disappointing
certainly part of me would be
disappointed by that but I'd rather do
that and have it be true to who I am
than to solve for what's going to reach
the most people that that was easy in
the case of writing the book where it
actually becomes a lot harder is on a
presidential campaign yeah right because
there this one giant popularity contest
is what this feels like actually it's
it's not what I expected I I think that
policies have less to do with it than I
expected coming into this so what do you
think is the most important factor I'm
not sure I'm figuring it out right now
but
policy for me policy is very important I
mean I think that money's money's the
most important factor money
is tactically the it's not what I think
should be the most important factor
there's two different question what I
think should be the most important
factor versus what is the most important
factor and I think that there's a big
Gulf between the two and the reality is
I'd rather kind of do it like I did with
woke Inc to make a bet on the universe
and on the country and on our process to
say I'm going to speak my convictions
and maybe people will hear them and
maybe they
won't and if everything works the way
it's supposed to work then that means
that if that's what the people of this
country want I'll be the next next
president I I
feel good approaching it that way that I
can put my head on my pillow at night
regardless of the outcome there's a
version of the world where that just
doesn't work and what you need to do is
you need to check certain boxes
particularly those that allow you to
accumulate large scale donors really to
buy the ads needed to reach people Etc
so do you think this is really an
advertising thing it's like how many
people can you get in front of how much
do you think it would cost I think
spending I mean the person who wins this
election this year all the way through
is probably going to spend about $2
billion two billion yeah so is that how
much you think it would cost to be able
to get elected president well I think
that you can't get elected if you don't
have a message that the people of this
country don't want but the
distortions created by the amount of
money that's spent via the super Pacs
completely distorts the system so it's
less that that amount of money will win
you the election but the fact that that
much money is being spent creating
Distortion and noise makes it much more
difficult for a guy who's coming in from
the
outside and actually just exp spend the
money where does2 billion go where TV
radio male direct M billboard are those
are those the people who show up to
votes yes in in primaries absolutely
okay yeah the fact of the matter is the
Republican primary electorate a lot of
them they're not your they're not the
world that we're talking to right now
it's people who watch old school cable
television that's where they get their
news and Old School radio like amfm
radio mhm that's the reality for the
Republican primary when do you think
that's going to change because
eventually those people are going to age
out it's going to change but I think
it's I think the the obviousness of the
fact that it is going to change creates
an illusion for how quick that's going
to happen I think it's like a 10 to 20
year time Horizon I have a very blunt
question question as somebody who is a
part of that like ultra wealthy upper
echelon like Elite members of society
and running for president I am sure as
shown in your books that you have access
to and can observe the level of
corruptness that exists in the United
States yeah now especially as you're
running for president are you surprised
by it what what how have you experienced
corruption I'm surprised by how broken
and corrupt the political system is and
I you're surprised by it that com as a
guy who's not naive to this right who
who has a baseline expectation that it's
a broken system it's far more broken
than you expect how so cuz I'm a
complete Outsider of this like how is
how is it surprising I have no IDE I'll
tell you it's it's surprising because
they create the illusion that it's not
so I'll just give you some you know
boring facts but it helps you piece this
together the max amount you can give to
a campaign in a primary for a
presidential election is 3,300 bucks
turns out you can donate another 3,300
for the general so add that up the most
you can contribute to a campaign is 6600
bucks that's a lot of money for a lot of
people but it's not enough to buy off a
presidential candidate it's just not
because it's going to cost two billion
there's a lot of people who can give
6600 bucks why do we limit it at 6600
bucks we limit it because we don't want
any one person to have undo or
corrupting influence over our president
that's why we have that system this is
all a
farce that's not where the money like I
don't have the exact numbers in front of
me but like 90 plus perc of the money
that's been spent on this campaign
season so far has not been spent by the
campaigns of the individual candidates
that are subject to these limits it's
spent by super packs these are these
separate entities where there's no limit
to how much money people can put in
they can put in a million they can put
in 10 million they can put in a 100
million and you have people putting
in tens soon to be hundreds of millions
as individuals why do they do that to
get influence so the very thing that we
were supposed to stop with the campaign
thing now the candidates what they do is
they show up at
events hosted by the Super PAC where
there are Mega donors in that room 10 20
people given millions of dollars a piece
that's who the candidate knows is
actually funding their campaign I mean
if you look at other candidates in this
race Ron sandis Nikki Haley whatever
these are people where the dollars are
really being spent by their super packs
the candidates know who's the super
packs are and I'm not saying these
candidates are good people are bad
people it's a broken
system many of them are good people
tainted by this system they're playing
the game as it's as it's currently
played and so what happens is they dance
to the tune of those donors the things
they say on TV or on that debate stage
or whatever that's not them speaking
that's some Mega donor speaking using
their vocal cords as a vehicle as a
vessel to communicate how much do you
think it would cost to be able to do
that like what's the minimum like is it
10 million 50 million more I mean you're
saying you're saying like if have your
own money influence if I were to
influence a policy infl let's just say
you know whoever's running uh you know
whoever's in the lead right now 50
million bucks yeah is is that the amount
is it 10 is it I think if you're talking
about
contributing mid to high seven figures
you're definitely going to have
influence on a politician if you're in
the eight figure territory you're in the
really special Club of people who are
then the Puppet Masters so the people
who can write eight figure checks
they're the Puppet Masters is are these
companies or people people what is the
message that they're trying to get
across usually is it depends on what
their self-interest is I mean different
people have different self regulations
in their industry yeah or or actually
even just pet policies that they
consider to be their version of what
makes for a better America that's
actually the thing is it's not
exactly as you'd expect in terms of it
all being directly relating to like
their business interest sometimes it is
sometimes it is for sure but if only it
were that simple have you been
approached for any of these for super P
stuff yes like huge donations say hey
we'll give you $100 million but did well
it it doesn't work it it never works
that way even for the other candidates
okay the way it works is there
technically they will say can't be super
pack
coordination right but but Rond his
entire campaign is literally being run
by the Super PAC so that's not his fault
that's not why to saying it's his fault
but it is a
tortured interpretation of how the
system was supposed to work in the first
place why even bother with the campaign
contribution limits I mean why if the
candidates entire the bulk of his
campaign can be run by a Super PAC like
most of the staff is hired by the Super
PAC the ads are all being bought by the
Super Pac and you know who the super
pack donors are and you show up at their
events to raise the money why bother
with the fars mhm so so the beauty of
our system is supposed to be that every
Citizen's voice and vote counts equally
regardless of the number of green pieces
of paper they control and that
culminates at The Ballot Box that's a
farce that's just not the system we have
in the United States of America and the
wor part of it
is we create this myth that that's how
it works when in fact that's not how it
works and so every politician dances to
the tune of their biggest donor it's
like as the sun rises in the East and
sets in the west it's like a law of
nature every
politician dances to the tune like a
circus monkey to their biggest donor now
in my case that biggest donor is me and
if you're investing in your own campaign
the way the rules work is that the 6600
limit applies to everybody else but if
it's your own money you can put in an
unlimited amount mhm so I've put in over
I think 15 plus million I have to look
up the exact number it's over 15 for
sure million dollars into this campaign
well I'd rather do that than be somebody
else's circus monkey but it is a broken
system and it is the Dirty Little Secret
in American politics and those who don't
there's the donor Puppet Masters pulling
the strings those who do not dance to
the tune don't even end up becoming
politicians because not the ones you
hear of they don't end up winning I one
thing that really frustrates me are the
bureaucrats that you talked about in
your book that then become upper
management or sit on boards make
millions of dollars all the while when
they're in like the Public Public office
they're just like a dancing puppet like
you said for those industries that they
will then join make seven figure
salaries after their term yeah it it's
the real one of the real divides in this
country is not between black or white or
democrat or republican even it's between
what I call this manag iial class in
woke Inc that's what I was talking about
the same kind of middle to upper
management that staff's corporate Boards
of directors or is the associate dean of
God knows what at some godforsaken
University to being the under Secretary
of something or other in the US
government to the person sits in the
ambassador to some second tier Nation
abroad it's the same horizontal pool of
people that are crushing the will of the
everyday Citizen and I would put the
super pack Puppet Masters in that
category do you find that there's a
balance though between going with some
of these large donors and getting your
own message
across like let's just say that's the
only way to become president that's what
I'm doing but let's just say that's the
only way to be president is that you
have to get these donations do you find
there to be a balance between it I think
that that's because otherwise then you
then it might never happen yeah that's
that's so that's what I was saying it's
one thing to write woke Inc like that
was easy for me the hard part is if your
mission is actually to change this
country you got to be oriented towards
your ends now I'm being an idealist
about this but my hope is in the modern
era versus at least even seven eight
years ago we can reach people directly
through other mediums that's why I'm
talking to you guys I'm talking to other
people reaching people directly on the
hope that we can still break that system
so I'm running against that system I'm
not running against any other candidate
I'm running against that system and
because I've been blessed to live the
American dream in this country I have no
real resources to be able to put into
this in a way that somebody who wanted
to challenge the system without those
resources couldn't so I don't want to
compromise on principle there are there
people if they if people want to support
me in whatever way I'm not going to
change what I say for them and they know
that I'm not dancing anybody's tune but
if people want to support me great I'll
take it but I'm not going to play the
game that the other candidates play in
in becoming circus monkeys but we will
find out whether that's a successful
strategy or not what would you do if
that doesn't work I'd reflect on it and
think about how else we reshape and fix
a badly broken system which is what we
have today a badly broken system and so
right now my my heart says we're going
to be
successful but there's no point in
speculating I'm going to keep doing what
we're doing exactly the way we've been
doing it and another you know seven
eight months it's going to be very clear
we they're on the Republican nominee and
in another 13 months it's going to be
clear whether I'm the next president so
I'm not naturally a plan B kind of
person so we're going to carry that
track and see see how far it takes us
which I think is going to be to success
in Reviving this country but if it's not
and the broken system is as broken as it
is that stops an outsider anybody else
coming in play by the rules but be able
to get elected without playing the donor
Puppet Master
game I think there's a lot of soul
searching not just for me but for this
country on how we break that system it
is corrupt and it needs to change I'm
curious why do so many politicians have
all of these campaign promises before
they get elected into being in public
office and then all of the sudden when
they're in public office nothing changes
for example Trump in the wall for
example Hillary Clinton saying that
everything is wrong with with public
policy everything's wrong with politics
and the bureaucrats but she's been a
career politician the same as Joe Biden
like why do they blame everything yet
change nothing is this because of that
distort
from their and prise all toing
TOs and
all it's a big part of it a lot of it's
a deflection tool to be able to you know
Advance their own political goals when
in fact the things that they need to get
done are the ones that their donor
Masters have told them to get done I
think some of this is also politicians
sometimes just make mistakes I mean the
US president can't do certain things
without Congress M and so you don't know
what Congress is going to going to look
like so I try not to make promises that
are legislative promises in this
campaign things that are contingent on
Congress the things I'm talking about
doing are the things that I can get done
without asking Congress for permission
or for forgiveness shut down a lot of
those excess bureaucratic agencies lay
off 75% of the useless federal employee
headcount 25% of the people can get the
rest of the job done these are things
that I'm going to be able to get done in
my capacity as US president and the fact
that I don't have promis that I've made
to donors about very specific things
that I'm going to do no the promises
I've made are the ones that are
transparent on media and social media to
the American public every day that's
what I hope will be what allows me to
succeed in a way that many of these
politicians of yesterday have not and I
do think it's going to take an outsider
to do that I also think it's going to
take somebody coming from the Next
Generation to do it I agree I I really
do I mean it's our generation your
generation that's going to Bear the
brunt of the $33 trillion national
deficit that we have and so on and so I
think it makes sense right now more than
ever to have somebody from the different
generation from the Next Generation to
lead us where do you feel like your weak
spots are where are your blind spots H
by definition of their blind spots you
know you don't know about them I get but
let me think about that cuz I've heard a
lot of people say experience yeah I
think I think that's a big one I mean I
think that but that's the over said one
yeah I think it is the overs said one
but I think it's a legitimate question I
mean I think that even for a lot of
people in the Republican primary base
who who view me favorably I the way they
view me right now you know we're sitting
in October we got time to evolve this
many of them didn't know who I was six
months ago but right now I think many of
their head spaces great young
man breath of fresh air that's what I
hear a lot such an important voice in
this race and I'm glad you're running
and thank you for making the sacrifice
to run and you have a bright future
ahead and whether you're president or
something else I'm so glad you're
playing a role in our country's future
that's that's that's where the headp
space is you know there there's the you
know 8% of people out there 10% of
people out there who are already
supporting me that's good it was 0% in
March so we've made some
progress but the big obstacle is getting
people from seeing me as a you know nice
young man with great ideas and energy
and Youthful Spirit who has a bright
future ahead and has a role to play to
say that's going to be the guy who's my
next president and I don't think that we
have grown up in an era where people are
used to seeing somebody who's 38 years
old be the next president but frankly we
live in an era I mean you're a Creator I
I respect that about you man but Thomas
Jefferson was a Creator he was 33 years
old same age when he wrote the
Declaration of Independence and he
invented the swivel chair while he was
at right and Thomas Jefferson wasn't
alone I mean Benjamin Franklin invented
the Franklin stove the bifocal
spectacles a remedy to the common cold
we don't have that spirit in this
country anymore and I think that it
doesn't have to stay that way we can
bring it back but that's my job to get
done if we get done I'll be the next
president and that's the work that I
have cut out for me in the in the next
few months ahead do you feel like you
have any other weaknesses though yeah
I'm sure we all have you know are so you
mean substantive weaknesses or electoral
weaknesses substantive sub yeah yeah
like in terms of being an effective
president correct I mean countless I
think I think we all do let me from a
personal perspective look I'm a guy who
has in my career
been fortunate to work
with very bright people in building the
businesses that I've built that was part
of my philosophy hire people smarter
than you or more talented than you in
whatever domain I can find them and need
them and when I look back at the people
who I've built my businesses or
Enterprises with these are some of the
most talented
people I'll meet in my life chose them
intentionally with that basis because we
started from scratch to build up I think
coming in in and running the executive
branch of the government with Millions
upon millions of pre-existing employees
who are there not based on Merit but
based on civil service protections and
other
factors is a different game than being a
Creator from the ground up and so I
think that that will be a new experience
for me one where I can't alone rely on
my entrepreneurial experience to do it
now I think that that entrepreneurial
experience provides some real vages that
people otherwise coming from within
politics or bureaucracy don't have but I
think the best you can do about your
limitations is at least to be aware of
them humble about them one of the ways
that I did build my businesses was to
surround myself with people who would
challenge me not just people who are Yes
Men Who agreed with me people share the
same principles and Mission and who are
skilled but often will disagree with me
and be unafraid to challenge me to be
the best version of myself as a leader I
possibly can be and I intend to lead the
federal government this same way as well
do you think the government has
recovered alien spacecraft have they
identified was the question unidentified
flying objects or alien spacecraft or un
flying objects evidence of aliens I I
would say evidence of aliens I don't
know so so the question I'm answering
yes to is have unidentified flying
objects yeah if you did discover aliens
do you think it would be in the Public's
best interest to know about it or not I
think it's the Public's best interest to
know what the government knows there are
almost no circumstances in which the
government should be hiding something
from the let's say that would cause
public Panic do you believe that maybe
it's it's worthold I think there's so
this is this is an ancient debate from
the ER of Socrates and Plato to even the
co 19 and climate change alarmism era
that we're in
today there's no such thing as a noble
lie doesn't exist people think they're
telling a lie to be Noble because the
public can't handle the truth we can
handle the truth we require the truth
and the reason people don't trust the
government government is that the
government doesn't trust the people back
and so if there's one thing I will bring
to the table we will be transparent tell
the truth about everything release the
Jeffrey epsteam Client List say what we
know about unidentified flying objects
say what we know
about how many federal agents were in
the field on January 6 I mean just give
it to us straight what do we know about
the vaccines before they were rolled out
for Co 19 just be straight with the
public release the Nashville transgender
shooter Manifesto transparency anytime a
government official has pressured a
private actor to do something through
through the back door that the
government couldn't do directly release
it make it known to the public when the
government controls like where they
choose to be honest and and where they
choose to lie I think that's hard to
draw that line and I think that they've
been a little generous on their side
with it um you decided to step down from
Roy vent because of your non actnow of
BLM and you know post the George Floyd
tragic death and broader stakeholder
capitalism and and corporate social
responsibility garbage all that exactly
but currently you're kind of campaigning
based off of being a huge like uniter
right similar to what Obama was trying
to do which is like be the great
uniter how do you expect to unite the
United States when you struggle to do so
with rent well I I actually think that's
a good challenging question to ask the
mission is different right the mission
of rent was to develop medicines for
patients who needed them that the rest
of Pharma had ignored and so we actually
did the company around that mission even
though there were people on both sides
of a political question related to Black
lives
matter now my job as leader of the
president of the United States is to
unite this country around our national
values so it depends on the mission that
you have so it's it's more that I
fulfilled that mission in my seven years
as CEO I oversaw the development of a
number of medicines five of which are FD
approved today one of which is
life-saving therapy and kids another for
prostate cancer another for women's
health conditions endometriosis uterine
fibroids and others that was that
mission now I'm on to a different
Mission and I think that the Obama or
Biden version of national Unity it's
fake I think their model of national
Unity is just getting other people to
believe what they believe and trying to
get the other side who disagrees with
them to compromise and then sing hand
hold hand sing Kumbaya that's not how
we're going to get to National Unity I
think the way we're going to unite this
country is by Reviving the
ideals that we share as Americans all
the way going back to our founding and
those are extreme ideals it's not
through moderation or being a moderate
It Is by embracing the extremism of
those ideals Free Speech the idea that
you guys get to speak your mind as long
as I get to in return that is a radical
idea for most of human history it was
done the other way the unbridled pursuit
of excellence and meritocracy that is a
radical extreme idea but I think the way
we're going to unite this country is by
embracing that radicalism rather than
somehow engaging in moderation and
compromise now I'm curious on the topic
of Roy event I'm really big into
investing and yafu finance had an
article about Roy Vince negative EPs and
huge losses lately who is sustaining
those losses so so it's actually really
important to understand the biotech
business model right I mean Roan's a N1
billion do or some odd public company
today and most biotech companies that
are even companies most biotech
companies that are one or two or three
billion dollar biotech companies on an
accounting basis their R&D costs exceed
their revenue many of don't even have
products yet that are approved but the
value of that IP as those products
proceed through different stages of the
process make it a lot more valuable so
in Ren's history for example there were
years of developing these medicines and
then sell them in one year to other
distributors in like a $3 billion deal
that was what happened in my last full
year as as CEO or or my last year and a
half as CEO so it's just a way in which
if you look at normal standard you know
industry outside of Biotech consumer
products or whatever you analyze it
differently versus an IP industry
intellectual property industry so most
biotech companies full stop outside of
big Pharma most Innovative biotech
companies worth billions of dollars are
not companies that in the year that
they're actually developing a given
medicine are recording EPS even though
it's the accretion of the IP value does
it worry you though that coo has sold
off so many of his shares over the last
year I have not paid attention to it
once I've separated from the company
I've um you know I've left my
investments to to somebody separate but
my view is that you know my My Hope and
expectation is that Ryan's going to be
an incredibly successful company over
the long run I believe even in the
businesses and Enterprises that I've
created part of what you do is build
great succession for yourself build
great teams that are a able to carry on
the mission such that what you create
outlives you that's what gives me a lot
of satisfaction and so you know I think
it's been a be of a year in the stock
market for a lot of people Roan's been
immensely successful and I give a ton of
credit to the team that's there I don't
take credit for that I've been out of
the business for a little while now but
I give credit to the team that's there
and I take pride in having for every
about almost every one of those senior
people there having recruited that team
and that's I'll lead this government as
well is recruit some of the best this is
the last one okay uh there's a video of
you out there I didn't realize you have
an accent and I want to show you this I
just want to give your opinion on this
all right let me see it no Mom I'm going
to be first but but Trump is so so way
ahead way ahead man but I tell them I
went to Har I went to they look at me
like
okay that's really funny hey uh V hey
hey man how are you
momy good to meet you good to meet you
yeah what brings you to this part of
town where you from uh I'm like down the
street actually oh that's fantastic so
so so what do you do uh I'm a student I
want to uh play basketball it's
fantastic so when you have you know you
can be a cornerback you can be a wide
receiver it doesn't really matter the
great thing about am meritocracy is if
you're really good you're going to make
millions of dollars and if you're not
you're going to get cut from your team
probably not going to have any friends
probably not going to get any girls but
that's the great thing about capitalism
right it's equality for all and uh that
that's why on day one we got to get rid
of affirmative action we got to get rid
of affirmative action to say about that
that guy's pretty good his actual V
voice is very good it's really good SS
oh my gosh yeah so this guy might have a
might have a future career is that not
you I mean I wish I was in my
20s that guy's pretty good yeah so maybe
when uh when they're looking for people
to mock me on SNL he'd be a pretty
good I think he'd be pretty good I'm
gonna tell you if you did a video with
him and you brought him here you'll get
like 30 million views we should bring
down let's get the guy guaranteed I've
never met him I came across this a few
days ago and I wanted to show it's
pretty darn this is gone vir good we'll
get that guy here that's really fun he
makes a living just off of impersonating
you know what I'm happy to I'm happy to
have spawned you know creative careers
and uh you know I give that guy some
credit I I have a feeling if we're
successful in this as I expect to be I
have a feeling that guy's going to be in
employment for a long time to come so I
wish him well in his career thank you so
much for your time I really appreciate
this this has been such an honor thanks
guys thank you for coming over I
appreciate it beautiful thanks I really
appreciate your time s went a little
later than
expect